Experience
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
And we're live in paradise,
ladies and gentlemen to my left.
Sure.
Berto,
Brian,
how are ya?
Wonderful time of the morning to you.
The maker of the great bus,
the haunting bulls to his left,
John Dudley.
Oh,
true.
Extraordinary.
And teacher of many great people.
And to his left
big wave surfer,
Shane Dorian.
Uh,
we're all here in,
uh,
the night we've been on this epic bow hunting trip.
And,
uh,
we,
we figured we'd,
uh,
grace you find folks with a podcast.
Uh,
we've had a couple of beverages.
We're out here enjoying the beach and uh,
having a great fucking time
boys and amazing time pair.
Can't say enough about it.
What are you doing?
Are you Instagram story?
John Dudley's Insta story in this,
we're going to do what's called a swap cast.
So this will be available on my podcast and John will get a copy of it too.
So it'll be on knock on,
which is the premiere archery podcast.
If you're not listening,
you're probably not really slinging arrows,
Aria.
Well,
mostly it just not doing them correctly.
I had a,
I had a guy and he tagged me,
you and Cam and his picture and he had,
he made a hoy of these songs of that picture.
But he tagged us both and he was holding up this book and he said it's about,
it's about ready to get f and serious and he,
I mean this guy had never shot and he finally got one off of Ebay.
The GRE listeners,
they are getting into some bows.
So ebay bu prices are going up.
Um,
neighbors,
uh,
insurance policies are also going up.
Yes.
Saw a lot of dogs that are hiding under the porch.
Yeah.
Based on and based on this hunt era prices brought.
We're all going up.
So let's explain this place because this place is a,
Shane,
you talked about it on my podcast and it is maybe the epic bow hunting
destination on the planet earth.
The gas is going to be out of the bag after everybody hears this.
Huh?
That's the problem.
Right.
But should shut up.
We should say,
listen,
whatever you do,
don't go to Lanai because it sucks.
People are not friendly.
The weather sucks.
It's ugly to look at and there's no deer.
There's zero dear.
Yeah.
Yeah,
they're out of,
they ran out of beer like two days ago.
They ran out of beer deals gone and
the kill only comes in once a month and they bring it in a rowboat.
Justin shooter sizes and an angry sailor drops it off at the beach.
You have to go get it.
Yeah.
It is like one of those tricky things where it's like you have to,
you have to like think of how much do I really want to talk about it
this?
Well,
if you're a hunter,
you appreciate it.
If you're not a hunter,
you're thinking,
what the hell?
It's cool,
we'll talk about it.
But it's,
you know,
when I came,
when I flew in,
I actually asked a guy on the plane,
I said,
um,
is there any cool places like trying to serve?
I said,
cause I'm actually wanting to get some lessons on how to surf.
And the guy said,
well,
I don't know if you're going to have anyone good to teach you on this island.
And I said,
well,
I've got a pretty good guy coming in,
and he said,
well,
if there are good waves,
no one here would actually tell you where they are.
So it's relevant
to what we're doing,
right?
Yes.
If you have a good thing,
that's a problem,
right?
Almost.
You want to tell everyone how cool it was.
It's the same dude.
What's that guy's name?
He shout out his name.
What does it say?
Your friend Gavin.
You're friend Gavin.
That's hilarious.
Good for him.
Yeah.
The guy with the bow.
I haven't just gave you a big shout out,
bro.
That's getting into archery.
That's legit.
Don't shoot your neighbor or his dog.
Yeah,
definitely go to a safe area.
There's not really a problem.
There's not enough safe areas.
I mean,
you would think that La with a,
a place that has 20 million plus people plus Mexicans.
I think there's,
there's shit to the numbers.
Like how many humans,
there should be more archery spots.
There's,
there's a few spots.
There's like maybe in the entire Los Angeles metropolitan area,
there's might be four or five impact.
Archery's a big,
but you go down there right at San Diego.
Um,
I go to a Bob Prom.
Yeah.
There's one one call performance archery performance.
Where's the impact?
What's the impact?
Our tree
crap,
I forgot his name.
He's in one spot.
Yeah,
that's bomb pro performance is at the Vegas spot.
This is a terrible time to like really pinned me down.
I would go to the,
but we're recording this podcast and my phone.
Um,
I think that's the place.
Yeah,
we
go to in Vegas.
I'm pretty sure it is.
In fact,
I mean feel free to impact archery in Vegas.
I live in Austin,
Texas.
We got one boat shop that's worth anything.
I think you have a new place though,
right?
Your country.
It's been around for awhile but it's under new ownership and it's pretty crazy.
Pretty.
But I mean we,
there's a million.
Do you not have the Google App here?
I'm looking at your phone.
I'm so confused cause I'm used to my phone.
Just go to safari on the top.
This mess.
Okay.
Anyway,
anyway,
listening,
we're actually in a Joe Rogan's.
Yeah,
it's making out.
There's a pair of binoculars here.
They suck,
which actually suck.
But if we're looking,
if we look across that way like 2000 miles,
how many miles in 6,000 miles to 60,000 miles.
I'm so glad we have Shane Dorian in here because he's,
he's got the true logistics.
Last night we had an amazing beach cookout.
Um,
it,
I can't say enough about that.
We probably should tell without really giving the whole bunch of an id tells how
this became a thing.
Like how the hunt game.
I'm going to play this because a [inaudible] I'm going to go way back way before
this,
what you're about to hear and we apologize for what you're about to hear.
Um,
Shane and icon it together in New Zealand last year around this time and as
we're tooling around New Zealand,
Hun,
he mentions like what we're talking about,
Hawaii.
We were talking about elk hunting.
We're just kind of covering all the best spots in the world.
And he said something to me like,
when I is the best deer hunting,
you'll ever find bar none.
There's nothing different.
And you're like,
yeah,
bullshit.
And I was bullshit.
Wouldn't check it out.
I'm checking it now.
Um,
and then you said the same thing on Joe's podcast and then,
and Dudley heard the same thing.
So Dudley and Joe and I were having a nice dinner in Vegas.
Yeah.
Lovely dinner with Joe's friend Andy stomps.
Shout out to Andy for crashing or dinner in the most epic way possible.
And so we're having dinner,
Andy orders about,
I want to say half a dozen Tequila shots.
We get a little bit excited.
Any other,
any orders,
a half dozen more Tequila shots and then he finishes it off with six more that's
accused.
So at that point we came up with this,
uh,
this was actually our facetime to Shane Dorian,
but we wanted to send,
we really,
really want answers.
So we actually recorded that.
You wanted to send a message.
So here was the message to Shane Dorian.
Trey
listening to that while fairly sober.
It's amazing how slow my voice was.
That was clearly like if I was talking to a cop,
I would just,
if I was a college,
wrote me right in jail.
You were wrestling those syllables like crocodiles,
crocodiles are to Griffey and who would be more like that?
Some sort of a slimy eel.
I had this,
someone sent me this message on my phone years ago.
It was a a car team they read.
Did they cut the original member of the Rudolph cartoon or the original Rudolph
thing that everyone wants to watch and the nightlife?
Yeah.
Where's the bottle opener?
They said stressed out.
It was a,
uh,
clay animation of that Santa Claus being pulled over for drunk driving.
But he had a bunch of coke in his sleigh.
Has ever seen it.
But no,
he's like,
what's wrong off the for
it was hilarious,
but that's pretty much how this whole hunt started.
Say [inaudible]
well we're,
we were in Vegas for shot show and one of the cool things about shot shows you
get down there and there's a bunch of other people that are in a hunting and
everybody starts talking like,
man,
we gotta do something.
We've got to figure out as a hunt and a look,
this is,
we got one more day tomorrow morning is couldn't be,
or you guys are going to have this afternoon.
I can't cause I'm here with the family and I have multiple obligations but I'm
six time.
I might have to leave them by.
I didn't say that Jessica,
if you're listening to this,
I think that this is like one of the coolest places on earth.
We'd get better.
It really is.
It's like glass.
It's hard to be,
it really is.
I mean
you
just empty or quiver in an hour
for me.
Um,
cause it's epic,
right?
Tons a year.
Lots of action.
Perfect going terrain.
In all seriousness,
once you're here,
do you feel like,
hey,
this is important place like this,
these kind of places
are important for hunting.
Yeah.
It's just not a whole lot of spots like this on the planet that are pristine.
I mean this is,
it's hard to get here.
That's one of the beautiful things about it.
It's like it's easy to get to Honolulu.
It's a little more difficult to get to Maui.
It's way more difficult to get here,
you know,
and that's what keeps people from coming I guess because that's a cool story
though to the island.
And the island was originally,
you know,
really the revenue came from pineapples and it was a pineapple plantation.
And when we're like,
my knuckles are bloody,
I don't know if your guys are from crawling around the knees and my knuckles are
bloody,
but um,
everywhere you go there's like little one inch wide plastic pipe on the ground.
And that was all the irrigation,
all the,
you know,
all the irrigation for the pineapples.
And he told us today that they actually,
um,
they buried that plastic,
a lot of the black plastic that you see where they've now ground grounded up
because they took the pineapples out.
He said the plastic was seven feet under the top,
under the top of the soil so that the moisture's stayed between the top of the
soil and the plastics so that the pineapples would actually grow.
That's interesting because everywhere you walk you do see that black man,
he said they've tried to,
they've tried to get rid of it.
But he said it was seven feet under the topsoil.
Yeah,
pineapple isles.
Yes.
Fine.
Apple Island is what,
you know,
the references for the,
for the island,
but access me historically has been argued as the most pure,
tasteful meat on the planet.
It's so delicious.
Just what they serve at the hotel,
those,
uh,
access meets sliders.
It's pretty insane because here at the hotel,
when they say venison burgers back in the states,
when they say Venice and we're thinking of Whitetail,
but here when they say benison it,
it's specifically is access that's native to the island and everything that
they're serving here at the hotel is the axis.
That real quick,
because when you get venison in America,
you're mostly getting it from New Zealand.
You're getting venison that is commercially raised.
A tremendous amount of elk and venison that you buy in America comes from New
Zealand because they classify elk isn't medicine to do sometimes Venice and all
of the year.
Uh,
I didn't know that,
but
when I went to a restaurant,
I went to a restaurant that's near my house and this guy is a really nice
restaurant and the like,
we have elk from New Zealand.
They're making it like it's a big deal.
I'm like,
brought it all the way over there.
There's poor elk are in some high fence.
Bullshit operation.
Congratulations.
It's okay.
It's like sadness.
Hey,
bring it over his slave that you shot in the head.
No,
I mean there's,
they're red deer and the stag.
Um,
and it's not elk in New Zealand.
It's red.
It's red deer stag.
And they're farmed over there like cattle and they're shipped not only to the
states,
less to the states and Morty,
Europe and Germany places.
Well,
one thing that,
that place has in common with this place is no predators,
New Zealand and,
and Lanaya there it's a very strange situation where they brought over these
animals that are not native,
whether it's a,
in New Zealand there's the stag and then there's red deer and a few other
different,
they're pigs in New Zealand
they do.
Now,
all those animals are invasive so they uh,
they go crazy.
They have to,
you know,
to control their populations.
When I was down there we were talking about the difference between the states
and here and they were talking about their need to,
you know the,
the outfitter community there wants to make money of course,
but they also want to conserve and protect that population of wildlife.
There.
Problem is the,
the population on that island doesn't value the wildlife.
They see all this feral.
I mean they see,
they see Shami and they see tar him tar and they see red stags as feral
population or a non native mammal that they shoot at basis and they,
so they jumped in a helicopter and fly around and they shoot these animals.
And what these guys are saying is at this point the mine as well be indigenous.
I mean these are the animals that we have here.
We need to protect them and treat them like a resource and value them,
which gives them a better chance to go on.
Well the tourism in New Zealand,
how much of it is based on hunting?
It's got to be quite a chunk of it.
Good chunk of it.
But what they've done over there,
I think,
not to put a negative spin on it,
but if they take a lot of like a lot of our American sensibilities,
cause I think most clients that go over there,
some European,
but the walking room American,
they've taken our American sensibilities and they've kind of turned it against
us a little bit that there's a lot of high fence,
red stag.
There's a lot of like come down here and shoot this $20,000 right animal,
which is a kin to throw it back to our trophy hunting.
But there are a lot of public land and there's a lot of awesome places to hunt,
which I think more folks are starting to find out if that's just kind of like
the dirty little secret of there is.
There was a lot of high fence,
like every single one of those really big red stags that everybody sees and
went,
wow,
look at that to New Zealand stag.
Let's do the same thing in South Africa.
They're all in the farms
bread.
Completely a negative thing,
but like,
but it's weird.
It's weird.
It's a different mentality.
And it's also at the same time you're looking at an island that has so much
diverse public lands.
I mean you can be in the center of the South Island,
it looks like high desert in Nevada and you can go to the east coast and it
looks like the Brooks range of Alaska where we were last year.
Shame.
Yeah.
And then she'd go to the west coast and it looks like Jurassic Park.
They don't have any tags and you can kind of like a goose with a rifle.
Right?
I don't know what I need juice rival days.
But yes there.
So there's no tag.
There are some areas where their arms are paradise ducks,
Paradise Duck.
So it's a,
it's a really cool looking waterfowl bird,
like a ton of the major waterfowl or is like go down there to shoot those
specifically they go down,
they want to shoot the pair.
Is it bad that I want to eat one when I hear its name?
Paradise [inaudible] I'll be the judge of that.
It sounds totally,
but it's like here.
I mean they compare us to hear that islands,
these islands are closed ecosystems,
so whatever you drive in here stays here.
Unless he's less these axis deer in this case or the red stags learned how to
swim.
This is how big 140 square miles.
That's crazy.
Showing a paradise.
Yeah.
This is this an audio only podcast.
The rare audio only podcast.
Lisa Jones.
That's a cool looking ducto man.
Yeah,
that,
that looks like a chicken fucked a duck.
That's
like a rooster was like,
bitch,
I'll show you who's boss.
I want to shoot that thing in New Zealand.
It's a big,
he is a big thing for sure.
We were there last year when the opening ducks and actually that's way cooler
when it's in flight because you get to see the full color.
Oh Wow.
Well how beautiful.
These access deer,
amazing.
I actually behind,
it's crazy,
Sam Yata photographer.
I mean it's
photographing in this next level.
I mean I've shot the main shot photos,
a ton of elk and deer whitetail and mule deer and all sorts of stuff,
but like it's so hot that the first so thin and just like the entire thing looks
sleek and like the spots and everything,
it's just,
it's crazy.
And for a little history on Sam,
Sam and Ben and I met up in BC was,
it was almost three years ago.
Right closing on,
we were talking about some stories.
We had a great time.
We had a great time in BC,
but the epic cover of Peterson's hunting magazine with me carrying that Elk
Moose leg.
Okay.
That picture.
Yeah.
Yes he did that.
Sam's a bad ass.
I want like a signed picture from you.
Oh yeah,
that's the one I want.
I'll send you the,
I would love that Sam,
what's your Instagram page?
Because you've got a lot on awesome photographs.
Just my name.
So it's just
Sam soul,
s h o l t.
So hole,
so volt.
And then you'd see the epic bus at Sam's got the bus or on.
That is so cool.
Explain that bus because that bus is so cool.
We were talking about it at lunch today.
Yeah.
So I bought a 1993 65 passenger,
bluebird schoolbus [inaudible] does a story tell you got a sweet deal.
George Bush's second term,
get a sweet deal.
Found it on craigslist,
just south of Fort Collins,
Colorado and basically bought it directly,
almost directly from a school district,
but they had totally rebuilt the engine and transmission.
So it's like ready to go.
Yeah.
How many miles did it have on the rebuild on the body was a hunter.
89,000 and then 20,000 miles on the rebuild.
So what'd you have to do Jeff?
Dooney suspension work or I have souls or uh,
it's,
I mean it's pretty stiff.
Where do you want to go?
I get,
I'll be able to sleep five in the bus and I'm also going to have a 10 by 20
a wall tent that sits up next to it so we can sleep as many as we want.
And the wall tent,
you're going to have hot water that pumps into the wall tent.
So you could actually take showers.
Yeah.
So I'm gonna have a woodstove in wall 10 to keep the warm it up and then the hot
tankless hot water heater will be connected to the end of the kitchen.
And I'll run it out the window so you can take a hot shower and a heated Walton.
And you talked about this while we're in BC.
Yeah.
So the bus idea.
Oh,
the bus idea.
The original idea was to do like a 12th state Turkey tour in a bus.
[inaudible]
brother and his business partner and I came up with this scheme and then like it
just ate at me.
Like I was like I need to get a bus.
These [inaudible] said that I need to get a bus,
you know,
it could be driving down the road,
like one would drive by and I'm like every one.
I was like,
oh looking bus.
It's such a good idea though
for getting around,
going hunting,
doing hunting trips and yeah,
and it's going to be some like ripped all the seats out and totally converting
it into my little hunting shack.
It's an awesome idea.
Yeah.
So spending the next year in a bus,
isn't that funny how like when you get something in your head
you are really into and then you start locking into it and other people are
like,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
And it's like 1990s eighties series land cruisers.
Cause it's the last years where they had the,
the front end rear solid axles and those trucks can drive anywhere and they're
not glamorous.
They don't look good.
But those fuckers never die.
Go everywhere you see e series land cruisers there insist indestructable yes,
of course there is.
There's a solid axle dude.
You'll find them on Ebay with fucking 200,000 miles on them and their 50 grand,
you know,
or maybe 30 I might have exaggerated
what they are,
man.
I mean the,
the,
the like there's something about those.
And so I'd be like,
death,
that's an 80 series.
My wife cooked.
The fuck is wrong with you.
So old Toyota.
I'm like,
no,
no.
So Old Land Cruiser.
Do you understand?
Like there's a time when they were making these fucking cars that will go on
forever and then they figured out like you don't make any money making cars that
go on forever.
That's the same thing.
Figure it out.
Europe though,
when it comes to like gas,
you go to the,
you go there and like our Toyota's there,
they call him the Toyota Helix,
whereas we're driving it Tacoma or uh,
you drive Tundra.
Yeah,
they get like 60 miles to the gallon and they have a diesel engine.
You cannot buy that High Lux Lux.
I think it's,
I think it's a,
you,
I call it the helix.
Whatever.
You can do whatever you want,
man.
I'm think it's up to you be the biggest one here you can do as
well.
It's a high line was what they call it.
But yeah.
Well,
you know Neil already,
you,
you know Neil Young,
he has a,
a farm in northern California and he makes his own biodiesel and he runs all of
us.
Yeah.
He runs all of his cars.
I'm,
she does.
Yeah.
Let's talk about new young 32nd motherfucker.
Neil Young's the reason why I quit concert security.
I was working as a security guard and great woods.
Oh,
all the people that did a martial arts with me all got security jobs and this
place,
and I got a job there too.
And during a Neil young concert is a place called great woods.
And Greg Woods is an amphitheater.
So there's a,
there's covered seating and then the back,
the cheaper seats are this lawn area.
And in the lawn area it got a little chilly.
So dude start fires and the security guards had to go in and shut down the fires
and riots broke out and people start punching people and it got crazy.
And I'm like,
fuck doing security.
Well,
I quit in the middle of a Neil young concert.
I put a Hoodie on over my security jacket and I fucking bail.
Yes,
I did.
Good.
I was like,
dude,
I'm not fucking getting my ass kicked or getting stabbed for Neil Young Neil
young fans.
He told me that bringing it back,
he told me that story in BC.
That's why I want to do,
it was crazy.
There was fires,
people are lighting fires and when one guy saw far as a shit I want to farm.
And then all these Neil young fans just starting fires we're talking about,
I mean I don't know how many
people,
Great Woods in Mansfield,
Massachusetts seats.
I got to think it's somewhere in the,
it's,
you know,
it's a big ass concert place.
Like I saw Sam Kennison there and Bon Jovi's like 15,000 seats.
So you know for sure thousand
of them were on fire.
It was fucking crazy remodel.
I mean this is like,
I was 19 so this is like 86 and you know,
young fans are crazy.
Hey,
chow is nuts man.
It was all year.
That needle and the damage done.
Oh southern man,
that was to make a fire.
It was dark man.
It got crazy.
I fucking bailed out of there.
A lot of people don't know.
I used to be a fireman when I worked at Matthews.
You were a fireman,
Forrest Gump.
A lot of people don't know.
He said,
oh Lord,
no,
Forrest Gump.
Yeah.
Every time I need a happy movie.
Which a story like you cause like super slow but really good at ping pong.
I was environment superstar and uh,
yeah,
we went on this fire call with this lady and man her house.
The problem with the thing that you encounter a lot as firemen and she'd go on
fire calls where a lot of the houses are not kept up at the level that most
people would keep them up.
I guess that's politically correct way to say it.
Corridors hoarders.
Yeah,
let's just go.
So I went on this link.
I shouldn't say no visual scrapers.
I guess I picked the wrong time to store gasoline in the bathroom
and I mean,
I wouldn't have classified her as a hoarder.
I would,
I would classify more as a cat lady,
but she had a vast collection of,
uh,
let's kneel tapes.
Oh,
I remember a track or cassette
cassette collection along with a lot of cats and cat turds.
She have
not as many as the city of Lanai.
Well,
we went to cat sanctuary.
Out here is 500 cats.
There's a cat sanctuary cage.
How you guys do other things besides hunting?
I've family,
Bro.
When you have little girls,
we have to do other shit.
You have to.
This is the only way I could balance this trip out.
I have to do a con game.
I have to say I know your family to
Hawaii.
Yay.
Where's Daddy?
Oh,
he's murdering animals.
Like Shane's anxiety level when he's not hunting is off the charts.
Super tense.
We were
really added.
Well,
it's so drying off here dudes.
Whoa,
whoa.
You point red bull and your wine.
[inaudible] is red bull and wine might be a first.
What do you,
what do you call that trash bag?
It's a new concoction.
Let's call this the Cat Lady [inaudible] and I've created it catch before,
but that you guys created ride brain,
which is a combination of Alpha brain and whiskey.
Now standing these,
serve that,
but drinking everywhere.
Back when he was a bartender
before the farmer,
the bartending me and Sharon
bartending thing at the trigger,
like national convention in Salt Lake.
Yup.
We did a,
uh,
we did a smoked grapefruit.
Tom Collins,
that fricking one.
Well this is something that you do two
that I have not tried,
but I do want to try John Dudley.
We'll take a bucket of water.
Yeah.
He will smoke as balls.
He takes a bucket of water.
He puts it.
I'm,
I'm not,
I'm not joking.
It takes a bucket of water,
puts it in the triggers,
smokes the water right.
Then takes that water,
pours it into these um,
ball,
uh,
ice ball holders.
What do you call those things?
Silicone.
Eisman yeah.
Will you make a ball?
You make a whiskey bar.
Whiskey bar.
You can smoke,
you can smoke water with like mesquite or apple,
apple flavored pellets or anything you want.
And then you freeze them.
And if you have a crappy bourbon,
you can drop that ice,
the smoked ice ball in and you can take a real like crappy bourbon and make it
decent.
That's it.
I'm ordering or trigger tomorrow.
I'm a crappy bourbon drinker.
I mean Jack Daniels considered a crappy bourbon,
but what does that considered?
We might get shot if we say that.
I would say more like anything under seven bucks a bottle.
[inaudible] from a guy who's drinking tequila and wine and [inaudible] cat lady.
Gentleman.
I like it.
I'm not sure that he's mixed.
Ology is what?
Right.
We just fucked up my mini bar by the way.
[inaudible] and ears.
Radical bear hugs verse a booze.
When my family comes back here,
I'm going to happen.
Fucking some really shitty look.
Well Cause Ron would be laying on the floor.
Maybe they're my friends.
They're family.
You got to let it go.
These guys are,
they're all killers.
They've killed tank.
Let them,
they need to blow off some steam.
They got PTSD
from rage.
Tried pan ladies.
Excellent.
It's a very good drink,
Shane.
I'll try the cat lady.
Come on,
man,
I need,
I'm a little bit of leeway.
You don't like the Cat lady.
I'm missing up deer as it goes.
Oh,
okay.
Wait,
listen.
And that ladies is pretty good.
It's good.
It's a strange cacophony of like
anytime you could say coffee on a podcast,
you win and that's when you're in drinking tequila,
wine and red bull.
If
stuff comes out.
Let's talk about how God damn fast,
these deer,
I killed one and I killed one because he didn't know I was there.
Every deer that saw me and he stood still and I shot an Arrow at him.
They duct that motherfucker like neo on the matrix.
I mean,
it was so amazing watching an Arrow going and I switched arrows because John
Dudley made me two builds.
He made me an arrow.
Bill was 625 grain arrows that go 245 feet a second,
and then 496 four 96 and four 93 86 thought it was five to 16 the lighter ones,
I think they're four 96 anyway there,
they're still fairly heavy,
but they go 275 feet per second.
I switched to the 275 feet per second arrows because these these deer with see
the Arrow coming out and be like,
bitch and just not even come close.
So with the 275 feet per second arrows,
I was catching hairs.
I got a couple of hairs when they were looking at me like I would like get the
air on.
I'd look at it as,
oh,
there's a hair on this arrow.
Or I literally would give them a haircut,
no blood.
They would just duck under it and it would just like catch the,
like the top of their head or the smaller back or something.
So we need to get you like a 380 grand arrow.
So no,
no,
no.
I'm gonna meet this,
I actually did it
gas with a winky about this and we did a whole,
I mean we talked for a long time about speed versus energy.
He's a big speed guy,
you know,
he for Aero Ducker's he explained to Wiki is to the people that will see,
he is a whitetail expert,
a whitetail deer expertise.
You know,
a very,
very well known editor or a writer and he's got a great,
uh,
I guess online webisodes semi live on hunting show.
Yeah.
Midwest White Dale.
I feel like the world of hunting very well.
Yeah.
And we had this ongoing debate,
which is really cool because when I have a lot of my guests on my podcast,
I like to get in and things to where it interests me because it's a lot like
you,
there's,
I wouldn't say argument,
but there's debate between this and you know,
a versus B and bills.
He's very successful and he has a very good following and he is a very valid
opinion.
But his opinion on an Arrow having a lot of speed in order to avoid an dear
dropping versus like say Adam Green Trees,
opinion of having just a super efficient,
very heavy Arrow that is maximum penetration to where regardless of what it
hits,
it's going to do its job.
And by dropping what we mean is when,
what today is a perfect example,
the deer here,
the sound trigger in the night lanai in particular,
the deer hear the sound of a,
a bow launching an Arrow and they bolt.
Ben and I were talking,
I mean talking like this,
we were just talking,
we're shooting the shit and there was at least two bucks,
two bucks and a couple of dos bedded less than 20 yards away from us and they
weren't even reacting.
And then I took,
I'm like,
should I take this bottle?
I should launch this bomb on this dope
and,
and he gives me a reason to go 70 yards.
I'm like,
fuck it up,
I'm going to go with this.
So I dropped back 70 yards and did the dough is really like,
bitch,
are you serious?
She's,
she slides to the left.
It's like she's in something like 1990s fucking break dancing.
If he was electric slide,
I got to have no shot exactly
where she was standing and she was nowhere.
I told you after that
like you hit exactly where you were aiming in the tendering that Deere was
swimming the Maui before.
You're so fast.
They're so fast.
I was like at 70 yards.
If they're looking at you and they're,
they react.
It's not like you're missing them by inches or millimeters.
They could be like feet,
six feet.
UFC fighters had the instincts of an axis.
You an enviable,
you'd have to watch it in slow motion.
Know what the hell went on.
Mighty mouse,
Demetrius mighty mouse Johnson.
The best pound for pound fighter in the world might as well be an axis deer.
Okay.
For Real.
I mean that's like literally what we talking about.
Like people who fight mighty mouse,
they probably feel like a dude who shooting and an access steer who's looking
right at them.
No chance.
But for bow hunting,
it is probably the best training you could ever have.
And we were talking about this because this whole thing was put together.
Shout out to Yeti coolers,
greatest coolers on the planet earth.
Ben O'brien,
a big EXEC at Yeti coolers.
This,
this whole thing was whatever the fuck his coordinator,
homeboy,
um,
this,
this whole thing was put together.
And while,
while we're here,
we were thinking like this might be the ultimate destination for bow hunters to
prepare for
any other hunt.
Yeah,
yeah.
You get to experience at all.
You get their experience spotting,
stock,
a diversity of terrain,
and then in the end you have a lot of opportunity and animals that don't let you
fuck up.
Yeah.
If you do like 15 minutes later you had another group.
Right.
That's the beautiful thing.
It's amazing training opportunity.
So bill winkies debate speed versus,
so the drop means the deer hear the sound of an Arrow,
which is like,
they hear the sound of a bow going off and they,
they,
they literally duct out not duck cause they think an Arrow's coming,
they'd duct because they're preparing to lower themselves then launched
themselves forward.
Yeah.
A lot of times people think they're ducking the arrow.
But what happens is when someone gets scared,
it's a lot like Sharon,
my wife is bad about this.
I'll come around the corner and be like,
hey
yeah,
and ducks,
so string it [inaudible] you're jumping this tray.
I'm just trying to say hi.
She's a strange jumper.
Um,
what happens is the deer,
they just pick their legs off the ground.
And that's the cool thing about videos is when you video your hunts,
you actually get to relive those funds again.
You can slow him down and watch him.
And really,
you know,
it's a reaction of they're just clenching up.
So they're lifting their feet off the ground.
So gravity is dropping depending on their body weight,
it's dropping him at asserting certain speeds.
Oh.
So the lifting their feet so that they can go forward
picking up as a reaction like ah,
and then once they spraying they're going,
but,
but the weight of their body is actually dropping that down.
So,
you know,
like with an elk,
obviously it's a lot more mass so they'll drop at a faster rate than something
that's lighter.
But a lot of times their legs are just coming up to the body and the gravity is
pulling them down.
So what is a bill winkies philosophy?
He really thinks speed is a more of a benefit than momentum or kinetic energy.
But in saying that bill is also very focused on a medium game animal.
So when we talk about,
you know,
a whitetail deer is a lot different than the elk or a moose.
So you know,
momentum for which is a heavier Arrow traveling and maybe at a slower way to
speed but delivers a lot more energy.
It's a lot like when form and he used to fight,
you know,
when I watched foreman or when I watch a lot of his older fights,
he never looked like he was hitting anyone hard.
But when his glove hit someone,
their whole body was taking a tremendous amount of energy because it was a big
freaking fists.
You know,
why aren't you,
you,
you feel like he wasn't hitting hard.
Cause you weren't there because something that's lost in film.
Like there's a lot of people that I've seen hit people and person and they just
have,
there's,
there's people that are built weird and George form is a perfect example.
George Foreman is a guy,
I've never met him personally,
but he has hands that are the size of canned hams there.
They're fucking enormous.
It was a bigger Lesnar's probably in the neighbor.
Brock Lesnar could have been.
He's a freak.
He could have been the greatest heavyweight of all time if he was fully
dedicated.
And he started from the time he was in high school and went straight into MMA.
But he spent so much time in pro wrestling.
But if you look at Brock Lesnar's,
Columbine,
hello cat lady.
You look at Brock Lesnar's combine numbers,
his NFL combine numbers,
they're insane.
He bench press 225 pounds,
something like 45 reps is fucking vertical is off the roof.
His long jump is insane.
For a guy who's almost 300 pounds,
he's a freak.
I've,
I've never,
I've seen a lot of athletic creeks.
I've never seen anybody more freaky than Brock Lesnar.
But that freaky athleticism.
What's beautiful about MMA that freaky athleticism does not overcome technique
and longterm training in,
in the particular disciplines of MMA.
That's why Cain Velasquez beat the shit out of him.
Whereas Cain Velasquez,
he's a freak too,
but he's a cardio freak.
Different kinds of freak.
Not a power look like yet.
Exactly.
But it's in one of those things.
You've got to be there to see him.
If you saw Cain Velasquez fight in person,
you'd say Jesus Christ wave.
But it doesn't matter.
But he's got a mind like it does though.
When you hit someone wrinkles.
Yeah,
for ages.
He's got a mind.
Cain Velasquez has got a mind and uh,
like his lungs,
like lungs.
One of the things they say about hunting is that what kills animals,
his legs and lungs.
Elk especially cause like being able to get to where the elk are.
Being able to like being able to like have the cardio.
So it's like,
it's not an,
it's not like a coincidence that a guy like Cam Hanes became a psychopathic
endurance athlete because he's obsessed with elk hunting.
I mean,
I talked to him about it.
He's like,
the whole thing with me was I had to figure out how to get to those elk.
You know,
like how do I get to those suck?
I'm tired.
Like how do I not be tired?
I got to start running.
How do I get more endurance while I gotta run longer?
I've got to learn harder to run hills.
I've got to run mountains.
And it's the same thing with,
with fighting.
Like if you're like an explosive,
super fast athlete,
but you run out of gas,
you're,
you're fucked.
You know,
like you have this short window of time to get the job done.
And if the guy who you're fighting could survive that storm,
you're kind of fucked,
you know,
because then you don't have any gas left.
And that's Brock Lesnar.
Brock Lesnar never really developed into the type of like fully evolved MMA
fighter.
But what he did have his,
his freak athletic body.
That's the same thing with George Foreman.
If you watch that rumble in the jungle,
George Foreman came out of the gate storming hit Mohammed.
I leave with these body shots,
even a better fight,
his watch George form of versus Joe Frazier where he literally picks him up with
shots.
He hits him and you see Joe Frazier,
his body go up in the air from getting hit because form was so powerful.
But Mohammed Ali was skillful enough so when the punches were hitting him,
he was sliding just a little bit out of the way,
just a little bit out of the way with each punch absorbing them but moving with
them.
So it took a lot of the energy away from them.
And I think that that's a lie.
You could say this is,
this is like,
this is like a,
an analogy to like arrows and and,
and,
and a heavyweight era,
which goes slower or a fast Arrow,
which doesn't have as much momentum,
doesn't have as much kinetic energy,
but it's quicker.
It gets,
if they both connect on point a at the same time,
foreman is definitely doing more damage.
Sure.
So if you have mighty mouse versus George Foreman,
this is at a certain point in time.
I got a bet on George Foreman.
I mean until we get to like
what are you looking for?
More cat laid more red bull.
Oh,
red bull calf ladies.
Here's another refrigerator in the other room
here.
Well here for sure.
Like that air of comparison is,
and we,
we were shooting just today and we were just messing around and talking and we
decided to shoot this tree just to see.
Yeah,
that's a perfect example.
The tree.
So Joe is pulling the side,
80 86 pages,
six pounds and his airways.
How many,
what's the grain?
Somewhere around 500 grains.
That's a heavier,
my,
I'm shooting 68 pounds of my,
my Arrow was 320 grant.
So roughly half a weight and much less drawl.
He did you,
he shoots this tree dead center does his thing and his broad,
it sticks right in the center of this tree and the era of stays in the broadhead
disappears.
I brought in a disappears.
It goes right up right into the insert.
Yeah,
I shoot the tree,
my Arab to flex off the side of the tree and the Brown had the side of the
broader,
the third blade and brought it,
gets stuck in a branch
and then he looks at me.
He goes,
have your Arrow
[inaudible] chasse arrows?
Yes.
Well I mean that's what you would've had Miley Miley Cyrus
is the name that John totally game to my 625 green Arrow set up,
which it goes slower but it does horrendous damage.
Joe sent me
and he said,
dude,
build me something fricking extreme.
We just had a conversation.
We were trying,
we're just trying to figure out like I actually downloaded a gift,
a gift file of virus.
Miley Cyrus on the wrecking ball,
85 yards
at my house.
And when air,
when his Arrow would hit my target,
the next time I would shoot Google model all I can see elk horns moving on my
target because it was still shaking from the Arrow that I shot before it.
Wow.
So when Joe said,
dude,
how's that set up doing?
Cause I had told,
actually we,
I built like three different options,
but I told him,
I said,
man,
this thing is hitting like her freaking wrecking ball because the target would
just shake and by the time I drew back again and wouldn't be aiming for the
second Arrow,
I could still see the horns moving from the first arrow.
Yeah.
So then I ended up downloading a Gif,
Miley Cyrus riding that wrecking ball back and go over there and I said,
this is what it sounds like on the drawl cycles,
the limbs
pulling back this Lincoln log,
all these tiles.
That's an accident when the arrows on play,
a bunch of Google.
All right,
need Photoshop work of Joe Rogan
stat on Miley Cyrus
right now vegans are crying.
This is no calming.
It's not a,
it's not a good day.
And why?
Unless you're drinking a cat lady and listen to Miley.
So
whoever on that fifth year,
I brought five extra hours.
Today I have a seven Arrow tight spot and I brought a five Arrow extra quiver
was,
I'm like,
today's my last day.
We're going,
how many girls did you bring on this trip?
Joe?
might be some kind of a record.
Farrell came off from that guy.
Let me,
we must clarify this when when Joe says training,
we're not training.
When these animals were talking about the training of spotting an animal stuff
and in making,
making what isn't efficient shot like it's,
it's a very ethical practice,
but training just means like opportunity after opportunity after opportunity,
meaning that you could get after these animals and learn how they move,
how you move,
how you won't be quiet.
Dark window.
Drawls just practice mentor
day of hunting here.
I mean you have more opportunities on spot and stocks.
Then the majority of guys are going to have an entire hunting trip on
maybe a season,
maybe
mule deer,
elk,
anything like that.
I think I have to soul man the first day,
which we will talk about island time and a little bit first day seeing signoff,
talking about an island time.
Listen,
they got it right.
You're an island boy.
You guys got it right.
This is the way to live.
The way I live is bullshit.
It's bullshit.
He,
oh,
everybody's off fucking nervous and worrying and stress.
I come here,
I'm like,
I'm so relaxed.
My kids are relaxed.
My wife's relaxed.
I'm like,
we're so relaxed.
Like,
Hey,
wait a minute.
Why shouldn't we just be relaxed?
Yeah.
It's one of these last 40 hours,
right?
It's Friday.
And we got,
we got here Monday and it's Friday,
and all of us were saying the other day,
we feel like
when I go into my son's going to be like 17 years.
Shut off the Trager first shipping of fucking grill.
Oh yeah.
Happy Birthday.
Yeah.
Tyler.
Happy Birthday.
Oh yeah.
Chad,
your board,
Chad Ward has changed the way I fucking cook meat.
Yeah.
Chad Warren at whiskey bent barbecue and his Instagram.
He everything.
Well,
we didn't have the chance to reverse your last night because we were actually
trying to just chill out on the beach,
but we ended up,
we could then Rameys
move la backstraps because in a move line,
explain what a move from the move on is a Hawaiian cheat.
Yeah.
MMM.
Really,
really cool.
Oh,
Miss Maya.
A little bit.
Continue.
By the way.
I've never listened to that song before you sent me that anime.
I knew she wrote that song,
but I really,
I don't even know if she wrote it.
She sang it.
Miley Cyrus,
she said more and more press time.
Yes.
I'm a big fan.
Did,
I don't know what you're talking about
Cyrus.
The last night though,
everything he made was super legit and I was blown away at how I've eaten a lot
of move on.
It's actually,
but I was blown away by like that side by side comparison can move on.
She'd compared to the axis deer and it was,
I was reading,
I was devastated.
I was,
I actually,
it was true because let's,
what's Kinda sucks about this whole trip is I wanted,
the one thing I really wanted to shoot was a move Flon on Hawaii.
Sorry.
Shane's playing my little violin as faces.
Um,
I hadn't had a lot of opportunities to shoot bouffant in states that didn't have
native move.
Lon and I always said,
if I want to shoot a move on,
I really want to shoot it in Hawaii.
Um,
just because that's me as a hunter and your free ranging.
Right.
And I had asked the guy if they had move on and he said,
well,
yeah,
but it's really tough to get up there.
And little did I know that.
Meanwhile,
Ben and Randy Warren had secretly arrange the hunt up and move on to your story,
which literally looked like New Zealand and they went up and I can't believe you
got to.
That's amazing.
We got,
we would have had more than two.
I missed one at 30 yards.
A good one.
Good one.
Giant one.
You needed a faster era.
I needed,
I needed a sword for them.
Well what do you,
you know,
you needed a mighty mouse.
I need him.
I needed him.
So what do you,
this whole thing about bill winky,
but before we get off target,
I mean for the archers out there,
like where do you stand on this?
Do you think there's like a comfortable medium,
like maybe a Tyron Woodley who is a powerful one 70 pounder who's also lightning
fast.
I think I really want the Conor McGregor where
I was going to say he's,
he's,
I know that,
but Tyron Woodley would disagree.
Yeah,
he is,
but,
sorry,
sorry.
I mean,
I know,
uh,
counting or talks some crap to you,
the last press conference,
but,
um,
I actually liked that Arrow.
The animal thinks that he knows what's coming,
but then when it hits him,
it's like what just happened?
Right.
Got there too quick,
because I've been at a couple different fights that you've invited me on.
Thank you.
When Connor hits people,
they think they know what it's going to feel like,
but then when it does look like when that first lefthand hits him,
their face really change.
Like,
I think they expect what it's gonna feel like,
but when they actually feel it,
yeah,
it's a totally different expression.
I mean,
I've been that way with in competition,
which I've,
you know,
I've shot professionally for a lot of years and then when you meet someone in a
match and then they actually stand next to you and compete with you,
it's,
you can tell on their face that they're experiencing something different than
they prepare for.
Right.
I've seen that when Connor hits people and all of a sudden there they just,
their face changes like,
oh
right.
I think that's what every competition,
Is that the same with surfing?
Yeah.
Like you're around some people and do you see it underestimating them?
Well,
not only that,
but like,
like maybe when you were coming up,
like you see someone who's on just another level and you go,
wow,
okay,
there's that too.
When you know what I mean?
Some live where you're like,
wait a minute.
And there's a lot of guys who just don't like really,
I'd like to sort of like the same way you're saying that like it doesn't
translate like live fights to film,
right?
It's like,
Oh yeah,
that guy is pretty bad ass.
But in real life,
like you can't believe how fast and how powerful people are like that.
With surfing,
I think it's like that with any sport where it's like,
you know,
you're expecting to see this guy who you've heard of or read about or watch
films or something and then you'd see it in real life.
You're like,
what the hell?
You got to be there live,
right?
Yeah.
It makes it music comparison to what we're talking about here.
Like maybe like a Dell.
I would go Pavarotti,
but look it up.
He's going to Google.
This is God,
this heavyweight named Francis and Dano.
Who's this?
A African heavyweight who's a in the UFC.
He was like,
what are the best fighters in the heavyweight division right now?
It's fucking terrifying.
And Frances in Ghana,
but this guy a in Ghana,
there's something crate.
He's just,
first of all,
he's enormous.
He's like 260 pounds weight.
I've seen him stacked bill,
like he's just built like a brick shithouse.
Yeah,
knocked down.
Andrea,
I'll ask you one punch,
but there's something about him,
like literally when he's walking into the cage,
he's his like
his daughters different,
I guess his body is like dance monitor at the desk is shaped clips people and
they just go,
what in the fuck.
But it's,
it's not like foremens like you've got to be there.
If you see him hit people,
you go there.
God can't take a punch.
I don't know.
You've got to be there man.
You got to be
there.
And did the impact.
Like when in 19,
like 96,
97,
I watched,
there's a guy that is one of those underrated heavyweights of all time.
[inaudible] name is Pedro,
his own and Pedro,
his AU was a like a real pioneer in,
in MMA and then more Thai.
And he uh,
he was training one time at this place called Beverly Hills Jujitsu and he was
kicking this heavy bag and he was a lump.
He was kicking this bag.
And I guess if you saw a video,
it'd be kind of impressive.
But when I was there live,
I was like,
Jesus fucking Christ.
It was just like three or four levels past anybody I've ever seen in terms of
like the amount of power that could generate with a kick.
And that's like the same thing within Ghana.
That's the same thing.
But a lot of people,
it's like there's,
there's something about seeing something live because you can sort of like get
an idea.
Like,
I'm sure you,
if you saw a guy surf in a video,
you be like,
oh that guy,
that's a bad motherfucker.
Right.
But like for the average person,
you kind of got to see something like
live.
Yeah.
There's the little details that you can,
you know,
sort of really recognize it,
it really,
really well.
Whether it's fighting or surfing or whatever.
Anything.
Even hunting,
like,
you know,
Ram,
he's not here with us now,
but he was here always hunting with us.
Perfect example every morning or at green tree too,
too.
Perfect.
Cut from the same cloth or campaign.
Remy made a shot on the move.
Flon uh,
your ear muffs,
ear muffs.
W when he made a shot on this Moofawn 57 yards,
it seemed to me like his air,
I mean an s pattern to the like to what essentially was a cantaloupe size was it
can't live size target that he's shooting at a 57 yards and he shot through like
six trees from a knee within like a added like a 45 degree angle with his book.
I would like to tell you about a shot that I shot John Dudley shoot a couple of
days ago,
but I need permission.
Let me just say,
tell the 1 billion people.
Let me just say I saw some shit.
Let's just move on.
I saw some shit.
I saw some shit that I would never attempt,
but it ended with a perfect heart shop and ethical kill an animal that died in
seconds.
That's what you're talking about,
right,
but we'll see us something live like you can get an idea of how hard something
is until you see it live.
Exactly what the expectation of what.
Let me tell you something,
what our guide said,
we've saw what John Dudley Davey ever seen.
Will Farrell when he said what just happened,
that just happened.
That just happened whenever.
That's what Joe Rogan's faith look like when he turned the wrong.
Well,
at least I knew what you can do.
The guide,
like holy
Jesus,
holy Jesus.
He just shot that.
I told you he was going to kill it.
He had to be there.
But it's like there's levels to everything.
There's levels to writing.
There's levels to singing.
There's levels to poet.
I don't know.
I don't believe that.
But there's levels to surfing for sure.
There's levels to everything.
Yeah.
That can't lady at the top level role.
Cat Ladies.
Good.
Good drink.
I like it.
I was skeptical at first.
Skeptical Lady,
but she can bring her claws out.
She brings her be listening.
It's a tally vineyards 2013 w for those listening.
It's a fucking no,
it's a room service bar.
It's a red line.
It's a three part red wine with a one part,
uh,
Tequila patrol
and a one and a half part.
A red bull sugar free,
what do they call room service.
But what do they call the room bars?
Any bars?
Rebars rape,
rape.
We've got a long way trying to figure out whether her bill Wiki is right or a
Adam Green trees.
Right.
So I'll say just one thing about Arrow weight or sleep.
So there's at a known distance Arrow weight,
doesn't matter.
You know how far you're shooting airway.
I'm all for shooting the very heavy Arrow cause,
but at a known distance you can reign something
and it won't move.
Well that's obvious.
I'm sure it's great that you to have your hair Baxter Arrow has an advantage is
when something comes running in and you have to snap shoot at it.
It's like that's it.
I think 37 yards and say it's at 30 but if you have a faster Arrow,
you're only going to miss about,
you're going to miss by a lot less and it doesn't drop as much.
Actually this much less Barnes bladder.
I'm so I think to answer your question,
I think there is a happy medium.
You know,
so like for you you're shooting a heavier bow so your Arrow,
like a heavier arrow is going to go faster and people with longer draw length
there arrows going to go faster and they can shoot a heavier arrow.
Did I,
wouldn't you agree though that like my knee,
90% of our like our like archery hunters will shoot like a medium yarrow.
No,
because of that I,
there's not that many like cam or Joe's,
it want like a really heavier with a heavy brought at and there's not that many
people that do that.
What do you shoot for then?
Like people who like exclusively Yukon elk or explicitly not Moose or Susan.
We hunted water buffaloes has two different errors in this group.
What are you shooting?
I shoot,
I shoot elite,
I forgot what they're called.
They're a 8.1 grains per inch.
They are elite.
I don't know why I'm drawing a blank.
How many green?
So you're full.
The victory,
the victory armor piercing?
No,
no.
Minor victory elites.
Gotcha.
Yeah.
Victory,
victory archery elites and there w 8.1 grams per branching.
Yeah,
I'm not exactly sure what that,
so for people listening like 500 grains is about one hour.
Is that correct?
John?
John,
call your mom
texting.
Refer back to a,
a heavy hitter that I didn't know the actual force of and went to the Arnold
classic to compete in like,
I think it was 2005 [inaudible].
Are you doing,
I was bowling the Vietnam War [inaudible] back when I was canoeing
competitively.
Actually one two arm classics thinking
tank.
Abbott was fighting Wesley Walls.
Who that's not an answer to the question.
What's an armful arm?
John Walls.
Wesley and Wesley knocked him out with the need of the face.
No,
in any way.
100% true for what organization?
It was for the Arnold Classic.
They had UFC in,
no,
this Ohio,
listen to me.
Tank Abbott was never knocked out by a guy named Wesley walls.
This is incorrect.
What year is this?
Is it Wisley Sim?
2005 or 2000 I was there live and cabinet.
Yup.
We've knocked out with a place in the second round.
Tom Campbell was never knocked out with a new face.
And the second,
literally the bell wrong pull up tank Abbott's a Wikipedia page.
[inaudible]
I'm so excited that I know something that Joe does.
Definitely don't for you.
Definitely.
You won't be excited in a few moments.
The powerful Jamie was here.
What's that?
Do you remember the fight that tank Abbott got his knee kicked in?
Oh yeah.
Maurice Smith out of his leg.
This is a lie.
This is not cat lady.
So when I went to the Arnold Classic,
I was invited there by Arnold and Frank Zane.
I went there.
I did win within what?
What'd you do for archery?
They had archery are treated to army of class.
And then after the second year I recommended to Arnold.
Did she get as Wiki?
Um,
I recommended the Arnold that they actually,
instead of having professional archery,
they have the nasty,
okay.
Ohio state finals there so that they could have the high school Nass program had
their finals at the Arnold Classic,
which I thought would be better for the sport of archery.
But anyway,
I went,
um,
do the UFC fight.
It was the first time in Ohio that they had that at the US at the or a UFC style
MMA fight at the Arnold classic and tank thought Wesley Walls,
I believe.
No tablets.
That's cabbage.
Korea,
when he's from Hawaii.
I'm going to tee,
this is true.
I'm not,
you're knocked out.
Cabbage was a k one one photo when I,
by the way it,
you know you definitely have to,
I just think you're incorrect.
No hundred percent I saw it.
So anyway,
I'm ringside corner so we're the fibers come up the aisle to the,
to the rain.
I'm right at corner.
What year was this first seat?
I think it was 2006 maybe it was 2005 I'll have to look at my trophy,
but that's true.
But anyway,
I was sitting there and I was all excited because I was getting to see tank
Abbott fight
beat Wesley Cabbage,
Korea.
He knocked him out with one punch and rumble on the Rock in Hawaii.
No,
no,
no.
That's definitely right.
It sets the Arnold classic.
Okay,
let me,
okay.
Arnold lost do Arnold classic 2000.
It was a UFC fight.
You right.
Is that what you're saying?
Here's the problem,
but it wasn't the Arnold Classic Sweetie.
But the time,
2005 rolled around,
the tank wasn't in the UFC anymore.
In 2005,
he got knocked out in rumble on the rock or he knocked out,
excuse me,
a Wesley Correia who is from Hawaii.
Cabbage is his,
uh,
his name.
He got knocked out in a rumble on the rock in Hawaii and that was a Bj Penn
promotion.
Bj Penn was a promoter for awhile.
Uh,
before that,
his,
he fought in UFC 45 and he,
he lost to Wesley Correia.
He got Tko owed and that was in Connecticut.
Um,
so that's Wesley Korea for that.
He got submitted by chemo before that,
he got submitted by Frank Mir toehold before that he got knocked out by Pedro
Huizar,
I think that was in Brazil.
Yes,
it was.
Thank you.
Before that,
he beat Hugo Duarte,
which is a very tough guy.
That was 1998.
Timing is all shit.
No,
let's clear this out.
Get on a little phone.
Ask Him who one.
I asked him what happened.
There's certain things that I would refer.
I would defer to your judgment,
UFC fights or not on that list.
I'm going to prove you wrong.
Well you definitely not going to,
but good luck.
Listen,
I've seen every cabbage or every tank,
Abbott fight ever.
I know who beat him.
I know who didn't beat him.
You know I was,
I've been there for a good percentage of them.
I'm going to say this as a friend,
as a friend.
I watched tank Abbott get knocked down.
You might have thought it was tank.
No,
because tank Abbott has it.
Good to you this long.
Yeah.
A lot of other guys do too.
All I'm saying is tank came out and what I was going to say is lot like Brock or
whatever.
I was excited to high five take and I was on the inside corner of where they
come out.
Right.
And I like tank came out and he was coming out to his music and he was jacked
and I was supposed to shoot the next day for the tournament and I put my hand up
like this for him to high five me as he was coming down and he was so jacked for
the fight.
I literally think he possibly ripped my shoulder out of the socket.
Wow.
Hard.
That dude hit my hand and he was like,
and I was like,
Dad,
any freaking hit my hands so hard
that I actually thought like,
where's my labor?
Matt Zen up in the third row have that thing
because it got hit.
So give him the Wikipedia page where I'm working on this cat lady is a
motherfucker.
Oh no kidding.
I know you're not.
Oh,
so does it go when you walked back to your hotel here on the night of the four
seasons in your face,
paint,
camouflage your bow and arrows and then you just roll it in
or seasons and melon juice.
Well,
here's the thing,
they're super friendly.
They're like,
did you get one?
The talker,
that Hawaiian accent.
How'd you do today?
Like think about that if you did that at any other hotel,
were any of the four seasons for sure.
Yeah.
Four seasons at Beverly Hills to be like,
what the fuck?
It's a terrorist attack.
You complete.
This is become John Dudley.
Trying to research is erroneous.
Gavin,
I know you are Swedish.
It was Wesley Walls.
I don't know who that is exactly.
That's why I'm be right.
No,
no.
If anyone,
well Ben has the fucking Wikipedia.
There's no Wesley while she about to 2005 right now.
Listen,
by the time 2005 rolled around tank wasn't,
I don't believe you was fighting in the UFC.
I believe his last fights in the UFC,
we're against chemo and frank near,
I think Frank Mir got him in a toe hold.
I think chemo got him in an arm triangle,
a head and arm choke.
Um,
I think that was his last fights in the UFC.
Shout out to tank Abbott.
If you listen and don't know disrespect well tank,
he definitely didn't get k owed by some dude.
That doesn't exist.
Did you get the shit kicked out of his knee on that one?
That one might I saw.
Yeah,
that was Maurice.
Maurice Smith.
Maury Smith was a world champion kickboxer and one of the first guys to how the
world class kickboxing.
He
was in white compression shorts.
He was how many cat ladies?
How many cat ladies did you have?
And tell me how much payoti was mixed in Russian shores.
He was struggling to barely stay alive in the first and in this second,
he literally came off the bell with this huge flying knee and fricking clock
tank in the eye and he was down to the mat.
And the next day I saw tank and Lou Ferrigno and freaking everybody else at the
Arnold classic.
And he had this huge fricking well and he was knocked out and one kick,
one need of the eye.
Boy,
I wish this wasn't an a podcast so we can,
well,
I always tell you the,
the Arnold classic seems amazing.
So Saturday,
Saturday,
I don't,
who knows what it is?
Saturday,
March 5th of 2005 here's what the event,
it was a mixed martial arts festival.
The Olympic weightlifting,
Arnold gymnastics challenge,
Arnold Dance Sport and classic.
Yes,
four 8:00 AM
9:00 AM or it's still early in the morning.
Go back 12 years ago so I can witness this.
Slide 9:00 AM
Arnold cheerleading,
classic dance team competition,
Strength Training Summit Arnold table tennis challenge.
While this was going on,
Arnold was fucking is made.
He was,
he was shooting loads and it was made.
Now we're at 10:00 AM,
we've had almost had a full day,
the yoga for sports clinics and then the arm arm wrestling finals.
Then the VIP photo opportunity with Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Amazing.
Then he Arnold strongman and then 3:00 PM the world record bench press challenge
and at 7:00 PM the end of the day,
the Arnolds strongman finals.
Where's the archery?
And there's a VIP buffet that for some reason,
no VIP LaFace slash dance party that starts at 10:00 PM slash dance parking.
Go back in time to 2005 the dance party starts at 10 and here's the real
question.
Do you dance first and get a good appetite first?
Some dance,
sluggish.
There's no way to like go to the first event that day and play through all day
without cat ladies.
Yeah.
By the time you get to yoga for sports at 11 eight
Oh boy.
Have you found this mysterious person that haunts your dreams?
It's true.
They're not even real.
The person's not even real.
Well,
the problem is cabbage has way more cabbage then walls.
Did it mean Wesley Korea?
Yeah,
but well,
whoever this Wesley walls guy is just googled up fictitional person.
It wasn't Walter the receipt for,
I believe for Carolina Panthers.
At some point I heard he was a bass fisherman on the pro tour
representative of Shimano.
No,
it wasn't Lezlie.
Yeah,
you're right.
You're right.
You're definitely right about that.
I let you off the hook.
He's dropping now
45 minutes.
It's impossible not to.
There's certain shit you just can't.
You can't question me on admission.
Mixed martial arts records are on that list.
Tag anyone out there?
I know they did.
Definitely not right.
Listen,
you need,
I've called more than 1500 fights.
I've been working for the UFC since 1997 I'm definitely right.
Yes.
Yeah,
I,
I've watched every single one of cabbages and tank Abbott's losses and wins.
Seeing them all.
I've never seen any cabbage fights.
Cavities is bad.
Motherfucker had a hell of a chin.
A Duke could take ridiculous punishment.
The Andre Arlovski fight was a big proof of that.
So is it Tim Silvia fight it?
Take some bombs.
Tough guy.
Tank Abbott.
Caled them in Hawaii.
I know.
I can tell you is,
oh,
I could tell you is three cat ladies in
modern,
that litter box toxo plasma.
This telling you
Wesley,
if you're out there wasn't,
he doesn't,
he's,
I'm real.
You gotta make him,
you're going to make him
west West Simms.
The beat Frank Mir.
That might have been thinking it would be stomped him.
Wesley Wall is actually,
I don't think West my house and
Oh my God.
Oh my God,
we got to cut them off.
We haven't got to cut them off.
We've got to cut them off.
Let's move on to other things that are more important to over this.
Wesley was guys,
there's going to be a Wesley walls.
It's going to be a new character that starts trolling your instinct.
It's not a rematch,
tangy gamut.
I know a one,
they raised it from the records.
You Illuminati,
flat earth,
hollow,
earth,
Earth sometimes fight avid on the flat earth.
Nobody land on the fucking move.
I'll tell you that right now.
Sores aren't even real.
Joe And I had an interesting conversation to change the subject earlier today
discussing like what hunting does to your psyche.
I feel like that's pretty interesting thing to talk about while we're here in
the midst of a table full of booze and and the great people that hunt,
so like talk about what we were.
I think it's the ultimate struggle.
I think that's why everybody at this table who also does very difficult things
is attracted to it so much because it's such,
there's such functionality to it.
I mean,
everyone at this table has ended the life of an animal and there's,
and it's a very difficult to do,
and like we were talking about,
these animals jump in this Trang and these animals like so tuned in to what
you're doing and your movement and your intentions that there's,
and accomplishing that struggle in getting through that struggle.
You know,
it's very,
it's,
it's very compelling.
And I hate to use the word addictive because it has so many negative
connotations attached to it,
but it might be the best word to describe to it because it becomes,
becomes a part of who you are.
And I know Shane,
you got this issue right and we all do,
right?
You got a bad,
but there's,
I can see him.
He's like,
he's like drawing.
I mean,
we've been talking a little too long.
It's like starting to get addictive is not like
they're,
the addictive is not the killing part.
The addiction is,
is the challenge to yourself,
man.
Mentally,
physically.
Some of the things that you can do to just to come up against that ultimate
challenge.
It's a singular event.
Like I'm go,
I see this deer,
whatever type of deer it is,
or I see this animal and I got to go get that thing.
Those singular events in your life.
There's not a whole lot of those things like your daily life is is super
complex,
right?
You're,
you're challenged on a lot of different existential levels.
This is like all the layers of humanity.
You Strip those things away
and it's also constantly changing and moving.
It's not like bowling,
like you step up to the line,
the pins are set,
you roll the ball,
you hope you knock them down.
You know it's,
it's so complex.
There's so many variables here.
Stalking,
did I step on a twig,
snap the deer pops his head up and looks at you.
I'm blown.
So many ways to blow it so many ways and it's never the same like said like
bowling or baseball or those things.
You were trying to literally repeat that.
The repetitive motion of that there's,
there's,
there is a repetitive motion in the process of drawing your bell and letting an
arrow fly,
but there's no repetition and what that situation requires.
Like whether you have to shoot from a knee or whether you shoot it at an angle
or whether you have to wait or go quick or off the tree.
There's no repetition in the actual experience of let narrow flight and deer,
which,
which is the most challenging thing because there's almost no way to prepare
and then the reward isn't is also like so primal.
You actually consume the animal you're eating it.
It's the most hell and here's the crazy thing.
It's not like it's bad for you.
It's not like you kill a bag of Cheetos,
right?
Killing and eating the most nutritious animal that you can eat.
It's,
it's literally double the protein content per ounce than domestic beef.
I remember like one time I talked to Andrew Zimmern where an interview like,
I think that's how we met at this for an article for a patient today.
I was talking to Andrew Zimmern about it,
which shaft traveler and he was like,
man,
I really think of like a killing the deer.
Like plucking it tomato out of the garden.
It's just the right amount.
Is it just right if plump and red is ready to eat.
Like I think of killing deer,
like I think I'm plugging that tomato and magician that,
that experience of growing that thing and slicing it up and then feeding your
family is similar to going out and killing something and hunting has made me
want to garden that have chickens and do hunting is flip the switch for me to
understand that like the feeling it takes to eat something that you've not only
provided but you've worked for and train for and and mentally suffered for it
some level physically too well and it's like a major,
you just have that real connection to your food,
which you don't have otherwise you just don't like.
It's the same thing whether you're a,
you know,
growing your own veggies or whatever you're doing in your garden or,
or going out and getting your own meat,
you know?
Yeah.
It changes what your food is peeling out of the cellophane like container.
Imagine that.
Like just imagine the story.
Okay.
Somebody saying,
okay,
you're a Predator here.
Align.
Wow.
Years down the road you're still a predator.
But somebody else is going to deliver to that,
that antelope to you.
Well then you're not a predator.
Amit.
Consuming you're a lion is you'll walk into a whole foods.
I'm just going to be like all the African animals and Sophie,
why I'm still a predator.
I'm going to eat this shit.
I'm still alive,
but I don't mind.
I've taken off my claws and I'm just going to eat it cause somebody pretty rare
for me.
Not only am I going to eat it,
it's going to be nice lighting or like a wall where it's presented in such a
wonderful way.
There'll be a sticker that tells me what's in it with crushed ice.
This little sticker for telling me what's in this,
you're so wonderful like you imagine how ridiculous that would sound to somebody
if you presented like are predatory history as a human,
like the present that we evolved from caveman men throwing spears at things or
cavemen going and eating the leftovers or whatever lions killed and 2 million
years ago to two the same cave men to men.
He's later walking around in a whole foods,
peeling off the stickers of a piece of pork and thinking that's humane and okay.
And it's also,
it's kind of a cop out because people hate it when you say you have to
experience it because until you experience it,
you really don't know what we're talking about.
But there is such a radical difference between eating a steak that you buy at a
store and what that experience is and eating the backstrap have an axis deer
that you had to sneak up on.
You had to crawl on your hands and knees.
He had a wait for this thing to be cresting the ridge for the perfect
opportunity to pass in front of the Bush where you draw back your hardest
pounding,
you're centering your bubble on your,
your your rest,
your arm on your site and you're just drawing back and you just make sure you
don't fuck this up and you see that our launch and you see it slamming was rib
cage.
He like,
fuck,
I got 'em and you see it run and he see it fall over and its legs kick.
And then you cut it up and then you cook it and while you're eating that thing,
you're thinking about what happened.
You know how that animal died.
You were there.
You know,
you understand this,
this,
that you respected in a way that no one ever respects anything that comes in a
ground beef package wrapped in plastic,
sitting on Styrofoam,
laying on crushed ice is not the same.
It's just not around
table.
All of us are accomplished in their own things that we do and work hard at what
we do and what we love.
We all have families and we,
you know,
we all have lives,
but we are all eaten up.
We are.
All of us.
Think about this.
That moment you described all the time,
it's all almost all I ever think about it.
It's okay.
Whenever I'm not doing that.
That's what I'm planning on doing it again.
Shane is like that,
but maybe worse than that.
Some people have ever seen
how powerful it is for all these people.
He's from Hawaii.
I'm from Maryland.
You're from give it to him.
Austin grew up in New Jersey Bar for New Jersey,
grew up in California.
We got a high,
when we get South Dakota,
like all these people from diverse backgrounds live in different places.
Find a connection in that same thing.
Like that experience is so powerful that brings people together from all these
crazy things.
And when some people said,
why do you,
I'd be like,
that's part of it.
There's a myriad of reasons,
but that's one of the things like sitting in a room of people that all think the
same way about that experience.
That's crazy
Patho.
I remember listening to a Jim Shockey commercial with Jim Shock.
He was talking about hunting and he said,
one,
I'm not hunting.
I'm thinking about hunting.
I was like,
what the fuck is wrong with this?
I had never hunted.
He can't relate.
I couldn't relate.
I was like,
wow,
this is because I had watched bunch of hunting television shows,
a bunch of hunting things before I ever got into hunting.
And I remember thinking the,
what I wanted to do was I wanted,
I was so disconnected between meat and the death of an animal.
So disconnected.
So I was like,
well,
I need to see it happen or I need to do it myself.
Something,
maybe I need to hunt.
So I started watching these hunting shows.
I would go to Channel Six oh five on fucking direct TV.
What are these freaks up to?
Strange low level,
you know,
area of the dial,
the channels where I never go to.
And then I started watching Jim Shockey show and then I watched Steve Ronell's
the wild with him.
And I watched Ted Nugent,
spirit of the wild.
And I was like,
what is going on?
Like,
what are these people up too,
you know,
got sort of this like weird desire to try this.
And it took forever before I actually finally did it.
And when I finally did it was with Rinella.
But once I finally did it and I shot a mule deer and then we're eating it by the
fire and my,
Oh,
I'm doing this forever.
This is immediate.
I was like,
I'm doing this forever.
Well,
we
first met me and Sam,
well we shot a moose and a two couple hours later we were in a tiny little house
and British Columbia.
You were cooking the liver and onions of the Moose you just shot and heart slice
out of the heart of the Moose.
You just,
you're hot.
And we were eating it.
And I just sit down and say,
well thinking like here's the guy,
he's been through more than I'll ever go through.
Here's a guy who's experienced more lights and a lot of folks whose like
discovered this thing and not only discovered it but jumped into the,
into the,
into it with both feet and it's eating heart and liver.
I mean,
I know a lot of hunters that won't,
don't want to experience that,
you know,
or don't,
don't open their minds to experience even organs or,
or whatever.
But you,
you jump into that thing and he said like,
I want all of it.
I want every piece of the experience and I don't want it.
I don't want to miss anything.
And then once you start to do that,
I mean that's three years ago.
And how,
how much has your mind changed about hunting in those three years?
A lot.
Well in those three years I went from being like almost exclusively rifle in the
beginning,
which is probably good way to get started.
Yeah.
Cause he's more,
more reliable to be like being almost exclusively archery.
And one of the things that struck me about it is one of the things that strikes,
strikes me about a lot of things about this crazy life that we live is that I
don't think most people are seeing everything.
And I think that we live life with blinders on.
I think one of the reasons why we do that is because life becomes more and more
complex.
The longer we live,
we have more and more responsibilities.
We have family and they have more and more responsibilities were involved in all
this responsibilities.
We accumulate debt and we accumulate all these different tasks that require our
attention.
And those things chew up a lot of your time on this earth.
And somewhere along the line he forgot a lot of things.
You forget that you're an organism.
You forget that you're an organism that has this unique ability to communicate
and share ideas.
And because of this unique ability to communicate,
we have this,
I mean this is what we're doing right now.
We're sharing these ideas and these ideas resonate with other people and they
elevate the way and expand the way other people look at life and their,
their words and their ideas to expand our,
our concepts of life.
And I think that when you stumble across something as intense as hunting or even
as an archery,
which is maybe even without a hunting,
I've said time and time again,
if you're a Vegan,
you should do archery just the same as for the same reason you should do yoga
for the same reason you should meditate.
But I think that when you stumble across something that is a real game changer,
it's almost like your responsibility.
I feel like in a lot of ways what I'm,
what I do with my life as I'm,
I'm like a little bit ahead in terms of like,
there's like a path and I'm a little maybe ahead of where I should be.
And I'm like,
guys not see this.
Come on,
it's safe.
You know,
I almost like my,
come on,
come on dude.
I'm telling you,
come on over here.
Look at this.
And I,
I,
I really feel like that and I feel like we all do that to a certain extent.
And I think some people are very,
uh,
hesitant to do that because they don't want to
be Brandon fucked us
brand is our fan.
But a,
I fucked us.
I forgot to put my phone on airplane.
Is that I think that hunting like a lot of things in life is,
um,
it's not for everybody and you don't have to do it,
but the experience is so intense that most people who do do it feel required to
let everyone know if there's something else out there that they're,
this,
the,
the life that we live inside these barriers and these,
this civilization confinements the walls and the structures of cities and of,
uh,
of a language and culture.
All of those erode.
When you're on a spot in stock in Hawaii and you're sneaking up on some deer
that just wants to stay alive.
Yeah.
No,
I mean it's,
it goes back to your role,
to your role as in humanity,
but also in society.
Like I feel more accomplished as a human being because I have the ability to
shoot an access to with it though.
It's like I don't,
I can't,
I don't,
I don't think somebody can do that as less accomplished.
But I,
I feel like as a part of my skillset is a human skill set of my,
you know,
my evolution has a person that has been a tool for me to use to,
to have it to gain perspective.
We were talking about some trips that I've been on,
like there's no way like yeah,
maybe there's some photos on social media or some things that to the note my
accomplishment or like what are killed or what the mountains I climbed or the
things I've done.
But the perspective you gain and you take home with you that you know,
kind of bleeds out into your,
your work life and your social life and all the things your interaction with
other people,
like those things can't be measured.
So there's some level of measurement that you just can't get from hunting.
And when we do stuff like this together as a group,
like there's just some level of,
I go to shot show or the biggest hunting trade show where we,
we had that video of us getting drunk and screaming and people's,
I think sometimes people who've never been to that show,
they don't realize like they,
the people that I see there and that that Sam sees there and the Deli's he's
there and then you see when you come and same for Shane,
like there's like a certain type of hub Mitchell give that person that you've
hunted with.
Like there's a bro Hug that like has more intensity and somebody who you just
know,
you may have had a drink with her,
had dinner with sometimes like when I see somebody I have hunted with like we
freedom,
we roll out,
like we will embrace each other.
And I think there's like that shared experience.
Like,
man,
I'm finally get to see it.
There's a little bit of that energy back in the room from that time we would
access to your hunting.
So I would say that's,
I would say that's a proof that Huntington next people as much as anything else
like it connects us as,
as people.
Yeah,
and there's some people that want it to go away.
You know,
there's some people that want meat eating entirely to go away and they don't
animals
to be consumed.
But I feel like where we are right now,
I mean I,
I understand this longing for some Utopian existence where nothing has to suffer
and nothing that's a doc,
but that's not currently available.
It's not currently available in the wild world.
It's not currently available in the human world.
And I think we as a species should do the best that we can to be nice to each
other.
But we should also understand that these animals,
they,
they do not have the capacity to understand.
They do not have the capacity for reason,
for calculation,
for a coordination of resources.
These things don't exist.
And [inaudible] is one of the best examples of that.
It's infested with deer.
It's great for someone who wants to come on and hear and be a bow hunter.
It would be terrible if you are a plant and
or maybe if you plan dairy and you'd be like fuck [inaudible] they had to kill
off all the goats because they brought so many goats on this island that goats
ate all the vegetation.
You get a point where there was no more rainfall.
Stop and think about that shit.
They ate everything.
It was a fucking desert.
They had the people that lived here like,
hey man,
we got to kill these.
Goddamn goes to the water,
comes back,
you know,
and you can't just like Kumbaya them and uh hey guys got us.
You got to eat.
Your Fair share of let us doesn't really work that well.
Let's say he said
wildlife management expert but there is like these islands like this,
he knows that you're coming from New Zealand last month and coming to this
island of Lanai,
you just realize what happens in a closed ecosystem.
Like a place where there is no opportunity for things to move on and that there
just is no opportunity for for biodiversity is like one of the most important
things that you could have here.
So when you have one or two species dominating the landscape,
that's trouble.
And that is trouble.
And so what,
what do you do at that point?
You can't,
like you said,
you can't snuggle these deer off this island and kill him.
You bring a share little arrows.
Yeah.
All in a big Ole Yeti Cooler,
wildlife biologists,
the Department of,
uh,
wildlife,
in California.
Is that a very interesting thing?
And it's very controversial,
but what they've done is they've outlawed hunting predators.
You can't hunt mountain lions.
So because of that,
there's very few deer.
And because of that,
you really don't have to worry about deer accidents.
You know,
deer and car accidents kill,
I think it's 150 people a year.
And there's,
I think it's actually 200 people a year and 1.5 million accidents.
I think it's,
I think it's about somewhere around there,
which is insane.
And John,
where you live,
I mean you,
you're the perfect person to talk to about when I came to your place,
dude,
we were there during the Rut and we saw a deer bouncing in front of the road
left and right.
We saw a dead deer on the side of the road left and right.
I mean,
there is,
people are constantly smashed into him,
right?
Oh yeah,
we did that on the podcast with you.
This is an estimated 1.2 3 million deer vehicle collisions occurred in the u s
between July one 2011 and June 30th,
2012 costing more than 4 million and vehicle damage,
4 billion,
4 billion and vehicle damage
according to the state farm.
Damn,
that's cheap accident.
1.5 million car accidents.
So I crossed 4 million.
It's amazing what kind of cars we make and it's not an age goddamn tanks.
[inaudible] he's faggot deer off the road.
That lady.
Wow,
that's incredible.
$4 billion a year.
200 deaths and 4 billion a year.
200 deaths.
That is truly incredible.
But that's an imbalanced ecosystem.
That's too many deer.
I mean,
it's great if you want to live in Iowa,
like John Dudley and whack 'em and stack 'em.
Yeah,
for sure.
But I mean,
unless aliens come down and spaceships and started fucking setting up blinds,
I would,
I would not flat earth.
Why would they come to a flight or at the same reason why we come to Lanai so
they can do heads or tails.
Aliens.
It's a target rich.
They have nuclear slingshots and they like to take us out from the fucking
skies.
Doug hide behind clouds deep.
Yeah.
We just got to get really good at like bobbing and weaving and the dudes who
have good headman would it go live on the street?
I'll come to the outcome to whatever fear they set up,
if it's okay,
but if it's like an in and out burger feeder,
like
all these years,
yeah.
Killian's made in and out Burger.
Imagine
matches.
They start looking into in and out burger.
They're like,
there's no one who formed this corporation.
Like we've,
we've,
we've gone deep into the,
they're the only person that doesn't have a button.
So all like Paleo people are going,
they're in shape.
Actually,
we physically superior,
fuller figured out how to attack the rutting elk.
Oh Damn.
They're running bull elk something.
Humans aren't this big truck hands by the whole foods
on the light post and Austin.
No,
do your Burger Pussy.
Shit man.
All we all humans do is consumed
and we just wake up in the morning,
consume and produce and produce.
I mean,
we could look at the negative side all day,
but we're were the reasons why there's irrigation and cell phones and satellite
dishes.
There's good and bad and that big ass TV,
a big ass TV that wasn't made by squirrels.
That's true.
I argue with vegans all the time and there's hundreds are trying to do the same
thing as them.
Like they were trying to control our consumption.
Same as you.
I think vegans mean well I really do.
I think most of them mean well and I think most of them will look at us the same
way.
A lot of people look at a lot of things that they're ignorant to,
you know,
and they cast the judgments on it.
And it's not because they're bad people,
it's because they just don't understand the full complexity of all the variables
that are involved in this equation.
That is life emotional attachment.
There were more view like veganism as part of their emotional view of the world.
Top the many bars that open that beer with a fucking custom knock on knife.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I,
before I get yelled at by my kids,
I've got to wrap this bitch up.
Uh,
it's three Oh nine here.
Perfect timing.
Our friends are picking us up to go hunting right now.
That's probably why Brandon was calling us at three Oh nine three Oh nine 30
you're getting picked up.
So everyone,
hey jammer at the 2005 in class.
Ah,
come on man.
Must Sims
to the face and the second round please.
Somehow.
All right,
well I think we realize that that did perfect.
The perfect Arrow is an Adele song.
Oh my phone died.
Put It on a Dell.
We realize that.
We realize that as Sam's vision for creating this hunting bus is a beautiful
thing.
Realize that Shane Dorian is addicted to bow hunting.
We did.
We realized that Yeti coolers,
the greatest coolers on the planet earth,
we realize we're coming back every year.
We're not telling you wine though.
You fucking Weirdos.
Don't go stock.
Don't please.
That's it.
A live from when I thank you very much for 200.
And Ladies and gentlemen,
uh,
please check out.
Uh,
knock on podcasts.
You're into archery.
Knock on TV,
but knock on podcasts,
podcasts,
damage,
right?
Sure.
I've got cat ladies.
Check out my new Instagram.
Lesley walls.
It wasn't walls.
We'll be trolling the knock on a social media feed.
Ross was a tight end for the panthers.
Oh,
Sam.
So Hall.
So you can check out the build.
It's all live on Instagram.
It's on your Instagram story or also on Instagram as well.
Do both.
Both.
Uh,
Shane.
Dorian.
That's motherfuckers on the planet earth.
Respect John.
Dudley,
you're the man.
Even though you're wrong about that.
Arnold Classic Bull Shit.
Can't wait to prove how you're definitely wait.
You're going to starve to death for it happens.
All right folks,
that's it coming at you live from paradise.
Respect,
big kiss.